Joy Reed's freaking out because as I've
been saying for a long time what they're
going to tell you on DeSantis is that he
is Trump but worse right he is going to
be Hitler with a calculator he is going
to be all of the things Trump was but
he's going to be functional and
competent unlike that buffoon Trump so
he's going to be even worse I've been
telling you this for a year watch Joy
Reid make Dave Rubin look pretty good
cartoon Creator becoming the voice of
the great white male freakout doesn't
end at Dilbert or even at Elon Musk it
or rather begins with white grievance
politics potentially becoming U.S
federal policy if Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis becomes president of the United
States which he is clearly aiming for
America will become the land of total
government control over women's bodies
black history gender identity how you
can teach learn rethink even talk
it would essentially be a more
functionally authoritarian version of
trump a more action less personality
type of President who's basically
offering two options pre-civil rights
America or total control of society like
she should be fired I I don't even know
how else you could say it like Florida
is the freest place in the world
literally in the world there is no one
coming for anybody here you could be gay
here you can be trans here you can be
black you can be white nobody cares we
get 1200 new people a day here actually
are one problem in Florida is that house
prices are high because they simply
cannot build fast enough you know in
places like California where people are
fleeing house prices are still high
because BlackRock and Vanguard are
buying a property left and right that's
a whole other problem which by the way
DeSantis is fighting because he's doing
anti-esg stuff here everything she says
there is a lie yes he wants to go back
to pre-civil rights America oh it's just
it's nuts but what is she really fearing
she's really fearing that people might
start understanding what freedom is
people might start understanding what
America really is all about and it has
nothing to do with the drivel that she
spews every single day and she's
freaking out about this book because the
book is the blueprint and there is
nothing more than a leftist fears than
information that might free you
but of course his robust PR team has you
thinking quite the opposite which is why
his new book titled and I'm not making
this up the courage to be free the
courage to be free
as a firsthand account from the blue
collar boy with a dream to take down
Disney and librarians it got scorched by
the New York Times Obviously it's
reviewer saying quote all the culture
War Mad Libs can't distract from the
dull coldness at this book's core
it will leave some supporters who have
encouraged DeSantis to humanize himself
sorely disappointed the world DeSantis
is building the reviewer said down in
Florida is one that uses the power of
government to make the Dilbert guys the
world feel comfortable they feel good
about themselves Center you know did you
know that this isn't even baby maga's
first book he also penned dreams from
our founding fathers published in 2011.
and it pretty much sums up what we
already know about the guy David Walt
streischer wrote about the book in the
Atlantic saying the most revealing and
consequential element of the book is the
insistence that the role of slavery and
race more broadly does not seriously
change anything about how we should
understand the birth and development of
our country
all right first of all I don't want to
be demonetized today because it would
hurt us in the algorithm I don't really
care about the money but if I say what I
really think about her we're going to
get demonetized then there's no
guacamole for you for lunch so I'm going
to write down three words that I think
sum up uh Joy read quite well
[Music]